hello and welcome to this video playing
FM Joe Flo who is that we check that yes
that's an FM but no name okay so he
played them the bishops the bishops game
oh my can tend to forget the theory him
of course I analyzed this when I was
compiling my the car wanna bring the
Khurana repertoire on chasuble the e4 e5
repertoire based on the petrov this was
part of it now why do usually goes a4 or
a3 you can play c3 of course yeah may
form knight 97 or Queen c7 it's probably
not a big deal and you can also probably
just Castle but ok there's nothing
particularly wrong about this Queen c7
yeah black hands I think very good
chance is here to equalize night h4 is
weird what are you doing there
hmm I'm not not quite certain what white
is trying here I mean you can play queen
of three and somehow try night at five
I'm just taking it just um it's um quite
quite harmless okay if I take eight for
what what is the idea taketake Bishop
takes t5 is that the idea
okay
I can take on e4 and then take a four I
mean okay it's got Bishop f7 and now it
doesn't have to ship f7 so I'm taking
this point
Bishop f7 Luke f7 is a tempo on the
Queen no so it's not getting the knight
back then
you know it just was just a just upon
absolutely nothing so Queen g3y I can
always take a five next move
one point of Nazi five is Bishop e6 of
course I want to play Bishop e6 oh I
could have done that actually
immediately as he cannot capture but
okay it should still be natural also be
quite okay
okay so now
this is why I hesitated for a moment as
spotted that he's got this idea I don't
know I don't know if it's really
dangerous I can just play this move yeah
it should be fine that's not that that
is helpful you know what's going on
did you already need to give this up I
didn't quite i mean yet rookie three
which is not not great but i thought he
would still do it
yeah I'm just material up for nothing
Knight f6 Queen d7 wins the night so if
I take Knight f6 queen is 7f 4 t3 it so
should win I wonder if I have got
anything more convincing I can actually
take him immediately this is maybe a bit
more precise
don't even see my clock timers here okay
[Music]
yeah I'm not so happy with how I plated
he's got more activity than I needed to
give him
got no time now I can just take I'm such
a [ __ ] losing this game is such such an
idiotic thing to do
I mean you're winning from move 10 yeah
and then then you whatever sorry this is
always this is always driving me crazy
if you play a game where the opponent
doesn't have a single threat the whole
game he just gives away material for no
reason and gets half whatever and you
just you just you should just win and
then somehow go I want to go 23 seconds
and then things got got away again
yeah minutes became okay so let's say
this is just the normal position and
then he starts to play this weird stuff
which makes no sense whatsoever it just
just doesn't fit into the position at
all it's just weirdly place pieces all
the way so I gave me this pawn and the
game is essentially over already you
just have to be good and converting then
next he gives me the exchange for
nothing and then somewhere here there's
probably a direct win but I mean it's
just from a material point of view which
is completely over Queen in some Queen
c5 rookie three wins the pawn yeah but
okay this is not really a big deal
I mean it's winning all the way until
here you know I mean I'm just too much
material up and now whatever basically I
mean you threatening nothing yeah I can
just play a 4 B 5 B 4 a 3 over and then
I play cringy 6 oh yeah these kind of
games drive me insane where
you just get get get the point yeah just
to take it and then then you play
something ridiculous like that yeah
sorry sorry this is not enjoyable to
watch probably this sense me too -
absolute insanity yeah okay if you think
yeah yeah what is this
no and the whole game is basically try
to just give me a point and I just they
don't just so take it yeah it's not a
thing of threat I can can even play this
and this till the end of the game and
he's got no threat nothing anyway okay
thanks for watching